visite du genre aussi pour l'italien
mario draghi dont le déplacement est
forcément scruté et commentés aussi de
près à rome où l'on retrouve tout de
suite natalia mendoça natalia bonjour un
déplacement que l'on suit également chez
vous avec beaucoup d'attention qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont dit exactement
effectivement ici en italie cette visite
est commentée comme un déplacement
historique de mario draghi l'occasion
pour le chef du gouvernement italien de
porter le message la ligne défendue par
l'italie vis-à-vis de la guerre en
ukraine l'italie soutient l'envoi
d'armes à kiev et compte garantir ces
envois sur le moyen et long terme draghi
prône également pour l'entrée de
l'ukraine en union européenne
a différence de l'allemagne il soutient
un processus accéléré d'adhésion de
l'ukraine en union européenne il
considère qu il en va de la paix de la
liberté et de la sécurité européenne des
sources proches du président du conseil
italien indique que mario draghi
n'entend pas faire pression sur
volodymyr seuls inscrits pour qu'il
accepte un cessez le feu si cela impose
des concessions qui seraient jugées
inacceptables par les uchronies merci
beaucoup natalie mendoza en direct donc
de rome